I was in Georgia I was in Atlanta
visiting my family
for Thanksgiving this is November of
2020 right and it was four of us in the
car it was my aunt driving
my mom sitting passenger me sitting
behind my aunt and my girlfriend sitting
next to me
and we get pulled over
but we get pulled over from like the
light like it like it flashes green and
they would just say I'm like that's not
even time enough
to do anything illegal
so pull over and my aunt rolls down the
window cop walks up to the to the window
and my aunt already has her lights out
because you know black people we stay
ready so
she hands the cop her license and she's
like I'm sorry like was I speeding or
you know just something I don't know how
you speed from a green but you know like
was I speeding something and he he bent
down and he looked at us and he said you
have too many people in the car
so he said you have too many people in
the car
and he walked back and I'm not gonna lie
I Googled it I was just like baby who
knows
you know it's 20 20 we in Coleman I
don't know if there's something you know
we could fit five we're technically
riding light like how
we have too many people and then while
he's gone my mind is just racing it's
just thinking about all the ways that
this could go wrong you know and I was
so nervous I was genuinely afraid not
just for myself but for the women around
me and
he finally walks back up to the window
and he's been gone a long time by the
way
and he leans into the window he has my
aunt back her license and he says
on behalf of Newton County we'd like to
present you and your family with this
Butterball turkey
Happy Thanksgiving
and in my head I'm like why'd you do it
like that what is wrong with you
[Applause]
I thought we were all going to jail
everybody knows the law of the cop has
gone the more jail you're going to
what took you so long did you forget
where the turkeys were
war was he wet he had my own license and
they went to grab the Target and then
the license fell between the seats and
he was like it's always something
so then he passes the turkey to my aunt
she passes the turkey to me
I'm just sitting there with it
looking at it and
in my head I'm like
everybody not being cracking this
and then we drive off and oh I'm not
gonna lie police have messed with me
before but like this is the worst thing
that a cop has ever done to me because
in a year where all of my friends are
out protested we're sitting around in
Brooklyn around the table telling
stories about getting their ass beat at
protests like civil rights leaders I
gotta be the one to be like yeah and
sometimes they give you turkeys you
don't even
[Applause]
it's a day for Thanksgiving how's it
going to defrost in time that's
terrorism